what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and it looks like we are going to get
exactly what we want from Deadpool 3. we
already knew that Deadpool 3 was going
to be a huge hit Deadpool 1 and Deadpool
2 were both fantastic but now Deadpool
is in the Marvel Cinematic Universe now
Deadpool can interact with the
characters that we know and love so we
already knew that Deadpool was going to
be pretty fantastic however then they go
and announce that Hugh Jackman is
returning as the iconic Wolverine but we
did have one idea
hey Hugh you want to play Wolverine one
more time
yeah sure
and now this movie has the potential to
be one of the greatest superhero films
of all time Deadpool and Wolverine and
Ryan Reynolds and Hugh Jackman together
everyone's excited and today the
director has actually shared a little
bit of insight on what to expect from
Wolverine in Deadpool 3. and again it
sounds like our dreams are kind of being
answered here so let's dive into what he
said also a reminder about the Marvel
Legends giveaway to enter all you got to
do is subscribe to the channel and leave
a comment down below I'm going to be
announcing two winners this week then
we're going to announce another winner
next week and the week after that so
keep an eye out on videos this week
where I will announce the winner in
videos so after it was announced that
Hugh Jackman was returning as Wolverine
some fans went out and said well it's
probably only for a little Cameo or
maybe it's only for a few scenes
basically a lot of fans thought well
he's probably not going to be in the
entire movie however director Sean Levy
has stepped up and he has said that
Wolverine is pretty much in the entire
thing right beside Deadpool the entire
time let's check out what the director
said in a recent interview with
sci-fi.com when asked about Deadpool he
said I can't say much thank God stranger
things has trained me to shut my mouth
more than is instinctive for me I'll
just say that to be developing and
prepping this movie that has this iconic
Duo together in an entire movie for the
first time a pairing between Hugh and
Ryan and Wolverine and Deadpool it's
very much a pairing that the world has
waited for for over a decade and I'm the
lucky son of a bee who gets to tell a
story about that pair the potential is
so rich and every day that we work on
the screenplay there are ideas that we
didn't anticipate that appear because
you're talking about the Ultimate Marvel
icon and the Ultimate Marvel iconoclast
so there you have it right there if you
were worried about Wolverine being in
this film how much time he was going to
get in the movie worry no more the
director himself just said I'll say that
to be developing in prep up in this
movie that has this iconic Duo together
in an entire movie an entire movie of
Wolverine and Deadpool that's going to
be epic then you add in everything else
that we know is going to happen in
Deadpool 3. this movie is going to blow
us away everything from the TVA showing
up and Mobius actually playing a pretty
big part in Deadpool 3 as well chasing
Deadpool and Wolverine as they kind of
jump across different universes plus not
to mention a lot of people are joking
around and thinking that Deadpool is
going to hook up with Miss minutes if
that is even possible I'm sure it will
happen but then of course we have some
pretty big reports from some insiders
that state Deadpool is actually going to
be bringing some people over from the
fox universes to the MCU and we're
talking about the original X-Men now we
know that pretty much Secret Wars is
going to have some original Fox X-Men
characters in the movie plus the
Fantastic Four and the old Marvel movies
like The Punisher and Daredevil we know
to expect some pretty cool cameos like
that but it looks like Deadpool might
actually be the person that bring some
of those people over to the MCU and
remember Deadpool 3 is going to come out
kind of right when all of the chaos and
confusion starts he's the first project
in phase six and phase six is pretty
much where everything kind of hits the
fan right after Deadpool 3 is the
Fantastic Four and I'm sure they're
going to start dealing with incursions
on the Multiverse as well and then we go
into the King Dynasty and Secret Wars
and hopefully Wolverine stays in the MCU
at the end of Deadpool 3. that way we
can get him in secret Wars as well and
honestly even if he doesn't stay in the
MCU after Deadpool 3 Deadpool can always
go back to his original Universe grab
him and bring him in for Secret Wars but
the best news is we are getting Hugh
Jackman's Wolverine in the entire movie
for Deadpool 3. it's just Wolverine and
Deadpool basically on a road trip
together and I know it's going to be
epic but let me know your thoughts about
this in the comments down below how
excited are you for this movie with
Deadpool and Wolverine let me know down
below don't forget to like the video and
subscribe to stay up to date on all the
latest news for live updates you can
follow us on Instagram and Twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof